hey y'all movie retrospective time going
back to our 80s childhoods oh yeah
[Laughter]
i wasn't quite a child when this came
out yeah you were a little bit older
than me i think i was 13 when this came
out so i was about the same age as the
goonies characters like the younger ones
yeah so i think this hit me at like
exactly the right time i might have seen
this in the theater i'm pretty sure that
i did what you resist again 85
yeah 80 i was 16 yeah you were older so
you were kind of more i was like kind of
the age range well it's interesting
because i this is one thing that's
always and we've talked about this on
the show before particularly ones uh
when we talk about movies from the 80s
that are very like have a lot of
nostalgia value for us and i'm always
kind of wondering yes i know like old
farts like us like love these movies
because we grew up with them we saw them
like during uh you know very formative
years of our lives
but i'm like i always wonder how
kids of today like would react to them
yeah so i found this video today
and i think he just put it up like a few
months ago or last year or something and
every now and then he does when he does
family movies he watches them with his
kids like he he did one with his kids
with jaws and stuff like that and it's
like really cool so he likes to see
because he kind of felt the same way he
was just kind of like look do i just
love this movie because i grew up with
it or you know to kids nowadays would
they react to it the same way so he did
a show on the goonies and he has a
daughter who's 10 and a son who was like
seven or eight they [ __ ] loved it
okay they loved it um they just thought
it was super fun and they loved all the
characters and they even like thought it
was like really tense and like really
scary at times and [ __ ] like that which
is exactly the way kids in the 80s uh
saw it i think well it's a real
well-made movie
i mean never saw this in the theater i
saw it on tv it was on cable and in
those days you're talking about crt
television it's real low res and fuzzy
looking
it didn't look that great on television
i remember just kind of going yeah
whatever
i really didn't have close attention to
it i mean [ __ ] i was surprised 16 or 17.
i was getting late i didn't give a [ __ ]
about that dude come on i was more into
like [ __ ] like blade runner and well
like i said you were older when i was
older so this was like a little bit like
i said i was about the same age as the
protagonist but i remember i remember
appreciating certain things about it i
remember appreciating that the uh that
the special effects were good and i
remember i remember saying well it's
kind of like raiders of the lost ark i
remember thinking that
and uh kind of like a pirate movie
that's what i remembered about it
but i didn't really um
i remembered that uh cindy loper was in
it you know
at the time i saw her as an older woman
i see her now it's like she's like a kid
she was the kid in the 80s i mean this
was just like a year after she got
really huge like girls just want to have
fun she was the music supervisor on this
so she actually she did a couple songs
obviously uh for the movie and then she
like runs all the other stuff there's a
music i remember the music video
associated with this movie i remember
that playing constantly yeah that was on
mtv all yeah i think i liked the music
video or knew the music video more than
the movie
but that was the music video was that
was the one with all the wrestlers in it
right well she usually she always put
wrestlers
in her videos but this one i kind of
feel like i don't remember if it was
this song which is the the main song
which is like the goonies are good
enough or
eight arms to hold you which was
actually supposed to be in the movie but
that scene was cut out and it was
actually i had the single and that was
the b side but uh so i don't remember if
it was that but that video was batshit
insane even by 80s standards yeah go
watch it it's on youtube it's it's super
fun the young tom
liked her music but didn't really i
wasn't really attracted to her you look
at it now she's a lot cuter than i
remembered her
she was adorable yeah honestly i kind of
feel like back in the 80s there was like
a whole little bit of a rivalry between
cyndi lauper and madonna yeah like if
you were cooler you liked cindy loper
you know what i mean because she was
like a little more funky i thought
madonna like punk rock well i think a
lot of people like madonna was like
maybe sexier yeah but i thought that
like i thought cindy lauper was a lot
cooler i didn't actually think madonna
was all that cool like madonna was kind
of cool like in her early days like when
she was still looked like when she still
had that like real distinctive look but
as she kind of got older and got more
into like the sex pot thing it's like
she wasn't as cool although [ __ ]
madonna didn't have [ __ ] on dale bozzio
from missing person she was smoking hot
now i remember her even [ __ ] back and
i mean she she remained smoking hot all
the way to the [ __ ] late 80s that's
just my memory of that [ __ ] she was a
penthouse pet so she was smoking hot
yeah she could say that too yeah there's
there you had it i mean i'm not going to
say madonna couldn't sing because
madonna yeah but sing well but i mean
cindy loper can sing too and honestly
like cindy lopper had a very very long
uh career she's still around now like uh
performing and stuff yeah
but uh yeah so she so yeah you probably
remember the video because like i said
that video was everywhere i had the 45
the single yeah for all you kids out
there 45 it's actual vinyl you know what
i mean it's like a little record uh yeah
i had one of those of the single and it
had the other octopus song on the other
side which like i said that was cut out
so the reason i think that this movie is
still so beloved to this day do you know
that astoria oregon where they shot this
every year they have a they have goonies
day
and it's in june because that's when the
movie came out in 1985 and they have
like a big huge thing like some of the
people from the cast and crew will come
there they have like big like goonies
games and like all kind of [ __ ] it's a
whole thing and this so this has like a
massive massive cult following still to
this day
so uh probably the reason why and like i
said the 80s
would this period in the 80s 84 85 some
of the best [ __ ] movies ever like
came out those couple of years uh this
was actually from a story by steven
spielberg he didn't write the screenplay
but he came up with the original concept
and the screenplay was written by chris
columbus who had also written gremlins
obviously uh the criminally underrated
young sherlock holmes which we should
really get around to reviewing money
because i [ __ ] love that movie and i
feel like a lot of people don't talk
about it uh he also directed home alone
mrs doubtfire first two harry potter
movies christmas chronicles 2
just [ __ ] tons of stuff
and it was directed by of course the
great richard donner the omen superman
lethal weapon you know just so the the
you know talent that you had like behind
the camera
you know immediately you knew that was
going to be a success but i think what
actually made this movie
so
memorable
was all the kid actors
they had
i mean that ensemble cast was just so
[ __ ] good and pretty much every
single one of those kids went on to
much greater things like when they grew
up the acting in the dialogue is good it
sounds naturalistic yeah it is funny for
from the
for the for the kid audience it's for an
adult it's a little bit tiresome
in some ways the humor is juvenile but
that's that's the target market yeah
that's what that's what they're
targeting
i can
i could put myself in the shoes of a
[ __ ] 10 or 11 year old and i think
i'd be like yeah that that would have
been funny i thought that was funny back
then
yeah i mean like you said this is
essentially like an indiana jones movie
but aimed toward a slightly younger
audience i mean 10 11 12. this was a pg
which actually is crazy because there's
a lot of swearing in this yeah like the
kids are just like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] all
the [ __ ]
edgy yeah for a kid's film yeah you you
would be dealing with a kid's film that
wasn't talking down to you
and there was criminals that like
murdered people yeah and [ __ ] like that
and some of the kids like almost died
and you know there were a couple real
dark jokes in there which i saw i
thought about star wars when i was a kid
that felt like i was watching an adult
movie back in 77. it wasn't talking down
to me but i liked it you know [ __ ]
robots and [ __ ] blowing up
i mean i do kind of feel like this was
more
aimed toward a younger audience whereas
star wars i think was just aimed towards
everybody yeah this was a more toward
kids but like you said was quite edgy
for a kid's movie yeah you felt like you
were getting away with something
watching it that's what they intended
because yeah because all the characters
were quite young you know what i mean
probably like i said yeah like 12 or 13
they're actually being realistic kids
but that's what i liked about them i
think like the ensemble um you know
richard donner said you know it was kind
of a nightmare like he wanted to kill
himself every day because it was such a
nightmare like you know working with kid
actors was always going to be this many
because he was like they're you know
they're rowdy and they were always like
playing pranks on him and [ __ ] like that
but
i mean he said when he got them all
together there was just instant like
chemistry
and the first part of this movie where
they're like setting up all the
friendships and they're setting up like
you know how the quest is gonna like the
you know getting ready to go on the
quest and everything
they all kind of like talk over each
other and it's very chaotic but it seems
that to me that the whole entire [ __ ]
seems like ad-libbed it doesn't seem
like anybody wrote that down because
everybody's just kind of talking these
people are talking back here these
people are talking up here it just seems
like very very organic like the whole
like relationships that they have with
each other yeah and of course you know
kids are going to be that age group's
comforted by that because that's the way
it is when you've been in a crowd of
them i remember yeah that's what i'm
saying so i think that's why a lot of
the environment related to it so much
because they're like oh my god that's
exactly what a bunch of kids that age
would sound like and talk like like
especially during that era yeah you know
what i mean
so uh yeah this movie obviously did
really really well when it came out it
came out summer of 1985. uh it only cost
19 million to make um but made 125
million
so let's talk about some of the kids
that are in it because
pretty much all of them went on to
massive super stardom which like i said
it's not really surprising considering
like uh you know how good they all were
in this so obviously you have mikey he's
like the main goonie and uh that's shawn
aston obviously probably best known
nowadays uh as being samwise gamgee in
the lord of the rings movies uh he was
also in stranger things i loved him in
that
uh with the voice of raphael on teenage
mutant ninja turtles like the animated
one from the two mid 2000s or late 2000s
uh he was in a zillion other things as
well
then you have probably the one that did
the most uh
d was the most successful in far as far
as like you know tent pole movies and
[ __ ] like that'd be josh brolin now he
plays the older brother brand this was
actually his first movie role uh he
probably i don't know how how old he was
when he was in this
um because this is james brolin you know
james mullen from amityville horror
that's his son right yeah so this was
josh brolin's first movie he's probably
he looks about 18 or 19. i think he's i
mean he's playing a high school student
and he looks about that age so this was
his first movie and then uh he's great
in this um i had forgotten how [ __ ]
funny he was
like your older brother yeah exactly
exactly
he's working out he's getting girls or
just starting to get girls they kind of
show some of that and he's buffed out
for his age you know
for somebody who's not [ __ ] on
gear which some guys of that age were on
gear but
so he's kind of like he's in he's been
placed in the movie to be everybody's
surrogate older brother he's the older
brother for the viewer
i did and honestly i love the brother
relationship between him and mikey it
just seemed again it seemed very
naturalistic like he's always he's
constantly picking on him yeah and
calling him a dummy and [ __ ] like that
but then you know there's a great scene
where you know he's constantly like
calling him names and [ __ ] like that but
then when he says something like when
mikey is all sad about something he
comes out and he just like hugs you you
know what i mean so he does there is
like a lot of love there even though
they're picking up yeah but he's also
the surrogate older brother for the
viewer yeah all right you know a lot of
uh a lot of kids don't have older
brothers yeah
through this movie you have the
experience of what it's like to have a
little older brother that's what they're
talking about
that's how i read it i had younger
brothers i did not have old that's how i
read the situation i didn't have it i
don't have any brothers or sisters so i
have no idea what it's like yeah so you
know
like i said i was too young when i
watched this movie to really get that
angle of i didn't care you know i didn't
really want
too young to pick up on what they were
trying to do and i was too old to be the
target of the movie
so yeah you know but as an adult i'm
watching i see what they were trying to
do yeah yeah i mean honestly like all
the characters in this are great but i
think when i first watched it i was
younger
um so i think i can relate to josh
brolin's character more now that i'm
older like i i appreciate his character
more like he has a lot of funny [ __ ]
going on in there too you know what i
mean kind of in the background but yeah
so this was his first movie obviously he
went on he was in mimic he was in
grindhouse he was in the awesome no
country for old men uh he was on he was
in w he played george w bush he was in
milk which is also a great film uh
sicario deadpool deadpool it was great
and uh he also played probably most
famously thanos in the marvel cinematic
universe uh so yeah very good that was
him yep that's him
uh so yeah he's huge in that he's mostly
cg that's mostly cg yeah yeah um he's a
great friend he's [ __ ] great
i mean i loved him i love no country for
old men i can't belie i don't think
we've even reviewed that on the show no
holy [ __ ] we need to do that i love that
[ __ ] movie i barely remembered i
remember liking it oh my god
it's so good uh so then you have
probably most people's favorite
character chunk
uh that's played by jeff cohen now
interestingly jeff cohen
um he was in like a few movies and tv
like before and after this but not a lot
he seemed like not all that interested
in acting and he actually was more
interested in kind of like the legal
side so he actually went to law school
and became an entertainment lawyer in
hollywood was actually quite successful
um you know it's it's kind of a shame
too and i was watching this other video
that said man he probably would have
made a killing as a comedian because
even as a kid
they showed like some clips of him like
on some interview shows he was on wogan
that uh british interview show and the
the guy terry wogan was like trying to
trying to pick on him a little bit or
trying to like provoke him a little bit
with the questions talking about his
weight and all this other stuff and that
kid just like danced [ __ ] circles
around him like he was just quick and he
was just like very very quick-witted
very funny and it's just like what a
funny [ __ ] kid and it's just he
really gets like all the best comedic
[ __ ]
in the movie i mean just his comic
timing in this is just [ __ ]
impeccable so i think that that's
probably why a lot of people remember
him like he's the the best character
like the [ __ ] with the ice cream and i
mean just like so [ __ ] funny uh then
of course you have the legendary corey
feldman as mouth i mean
[ __ ] corey feldman man he was
honestly i think he was one of the best
child actors
of all time i mean he was just i mean he
was in stand by me he was fantastic in
that he was in so many he was in lost
boys he was a little bit older then
but everything that he was in as a kid
he's [ __ ] great i mean you could tell
that
because you know i'm not a big fan of
child actors usually um usually they're
annoying usually there's a sale by date
yeah but i'm good for a couple rolls and
get the [ __ ] out of here and then you
see the dude he's worthless
overweight [ __ ] druggie yeah but i
mean you're putting too much fame and
too much money on a young kid they just
can't it's a lot of pressure i mean you
can't develop properly yeah it's not and
it's not a lazy and it's not a normal
life you know what i mean so it's yeah
it's going to cause problems yeah and
then there's [ __ ] predation and weird
[ __ ] happening over there man thinking
which did happen at corey phelps yeah
but i don't want to deny it but there it
is that's
yeah grooming but i mean he was great in
this um and
he plays
it's it's good because he plays like a
character that could very well have been
like super obnoxious because he is kind
of like
a troll
i mean he does like the whole thing that
he does like at the beginning when
mikey and bran's mom comes home and said
oh we're moving and i hired this uh this
lady to like help us move and she
doesn't speak any english
and then mouth says oh i speak spanish
i'll translate and then he starts
telling her like all this [ __ ] up [ __ ]
yeah like don't go in the attic that's
where my that's where dad's sex dungeon
is and like all this always separate
your drugs like this is the heroine goes
in here it's just like that and it's
just but he plays it off so well that
he's still like really likable
even though he's being like a complete
obnoxious [ __ ] uh so then obviously
you have jonathan ki haiquan uh who
played data this is a very similar role
to what he played in indiana jones and
the temperature he was short round
obviously uh this one he's kind of like
the gadget kid whatever happened to that
guy uh he was in a bunch of stuff he was
in a bunch of more movies later he was
in like encino man and stuff like that
he did a [ __ ] ton of tv okay um he was
on head of the class [ __ ] like that he's
still in tv i think he still does tv
nowadays so he's still around all right
um and then you have kind of like the
older kid like the older girls who kind
of like tag along uh then you have to
carry green as andy she was in um some
stuff she was in a movie called lucas if
you guys remember that one wasn't i feel
like winona ryder was in that or
somebody she was also in a movie with
john candy called summer rental if
anybody remembers that one
uh but then she kind of went more behind
the camera she went on and founded her
own movie production company
and then you have martha plimpton as
steph
and she was in
[ __ ] tons of stuff she dated river
phoenix for a while actually i think
they met uh when they were doing running
on empty but she was also in mosquito
coast she was in parenthood um she was
in a [ __ ] ton of tv shows uh actually
probably best known as a broadway
actress she does a lot of broadway a lot
of stage um if you look at her wikipedia
page it's like [ __ ]
movies
tv shows like stage she was in [ __ ]
tons of [ __ ] yeah river phoenix man i
forgot about that guy yeah there's i
remember when they dated because she was
kind of uh this
her being in the goonies i mean even
though she's kind of like a minor role
in this yeah um this kind of like
catapulted her to fame so she was kind
of in a lot i remember his brother
appeared and [ __ ] you know when he
first showed up walking you're thinking
what is this the booby prize brother or
something what the hell is that the
booby fries brother and all of a sudden
this [ __ ] [ __ ] climb to
stardom you know [ __ ] like getting
oscar nominations and [ __ ] and then the
[ __ ] the
did that [ __ ] the little roman flick
what was that roman flick that he did
where he played the emperor yeah that
was a really good role that he did but
did he was in that cowboy flick that one
was pretty weird yeah pretty good and
then uh comes back as the joker [ __ ]
knocks it out of the park with one of
the [ __ ] best batman
universe movies the [ __ ]
made so far we didn't see the new batman
i've been hearing mixed stuff about it i
heard it's okay some of you are saying
no it's terrible just
our friend toby really liked it he
thought it was bad
i make my own i'll i'll make my own
judgment on it when i see it yeah i mean
i'm just kind of pissed that it's it
evidently is not in the same universe as
the joaquin phoenix joker
it should have been well what are you
gonna do it's like you know it's
probably like different people working
on it it's like well you know sometimes
it's you want to make a movie and it's
like we don't want to have to worry
about like all the rules that we
established over there we want to just
kind of like do our own thing like i get
that that'd have been really cool though
yeah i know but what do you know what
are you gonna do make your own movie
yeah um and then you have obviously
sloth the lovable deformed man
who was actually i've forgotten but he
was actually one of the fratellis who
were the bad guys he's their brother
he's like the deformed one now he was
actually played by a football player for
the oakland raiders john matusak now he
was in a bunch of other movies too like
not a bunch but he was inside he was in
north dallas 40 and some other ones uh
he actually died in 1989 only four years
after this movie came out uh he was only
38 years old uh he actually he
accidentally overdosed on painkillers
darbaset
and he died so yeah that's kind of a
shame but uh yeah i kind of feel like
sloth is one of the most memorable
characters you can still buy shirts
nowadays that have [ __ ] sloth on it
so you know and then you have obviously
the fratellis the bad guys uh ann ramsey
robert davey and joe pantoliano
pantaliano who was great in memento and
many other things as well so yeah i said
okay now i had forgotten i remembered
that
they that there was like a criminal gang
that were chasing the kids
but i could you because you said you had
forgotten when the movie opens
i had forgotten what a what a strange
opening this movie has there's no music
or anything it just says the title the
goonies and it kind of fades back into
the black
and then it goes right to
a prison
like a jail cell and a cop like goes
into the cell and there's a guy like
hanging there yeah and i was just like
oh yeah i forgot that it opened like
this i remembered like that their
criminals were there and they busted out
and everything but i forgot that the
movie opened on that so i was like that
was pretty ballsy yeah like because all
of the marketing was all targeted toward
kids stuff and they're like here you go
kids here's a man hanging himself in a
prison cell
and then he's not dead though but like
he he kind of like cold [ __ ] the cop
and then you know he escapes from jail
and then they pretty much like set they
don't set the jail on fire but they just
kind of like put fire around so the cops
can't get out and so then they take off
and then then it goes to
you know the kids and like their story
so i'm sure pretty much everybody knows
the story of the goonies right it's
these kids they live in this kind of
working-class neighborhood in astoria
oregon called the goon docks and the
local country club has decided that
they're going to expand and so they're
going to tear out their whole
neighborhood and make a golf course so
they're going to foreclose on all their
houses so they all have to move and
they're all really bummed out about it
because they like it there and they
don't all want to move away from each
other so
they decide for one last weekend that
they're going to have one last adventure
like all together
and because
brand failed his driving test and can't
take them anywhere they decide they're
just gonna poke around in the attic
while they're in the attic uh they find
a bunch of mikey's dad stuff and mikey's
dad is like the museum curator in town
and they find a bunch of stuff like
relating to the local legend the pirate
known as one-eyed willy which that's a
dick it's a dick joke i mean obviously
and that well that's one of those jokes
that like if you're maybe like 10 or 11
and you're watching the movie like it'll
just go shoot like right over your head
but if you're watching when you're adult
you're like you mean a dick yeah he's a
dick pirate yeah
but yeah that's exactly what he is i
mean he does literally because they find
his skeleton later but he does literally
have one eye but
yeah one-eyed willy i mean that's that's
a dick chip
but yeah so they find the map they find
some other [ __ ] they find this article
about this guy back in the 30s who went
to look for it and disappeared and
they're like you know this is maybe this
is around here and brand's like you know
what whatever it's like everybody's
looked for that it's like it's not there
it's a legend whatever but they're like
come on you know we this is last weekend
we're gonna be here
let's have this one adventure together
and then there's there's kind of like
there well there's kind of like a hint
that they've done this kind of stuff
before which i kind of like you know
what i mean like this is something they
do every weekend they go on some like
little adventure you know so uh so yeah
so they decide they're gonna go try to
find this pirate treasure
and it leads them to this restaurant
which is closed for the season because
it's autumn
and it turns out that the fratellis the
escaped crime family are that's are
using that as their hideout so because
the kids have to go in there to get down
into the underground to find where uh
one one-eyed willy's treasure is uh them
and the crime family kind of like
you know uh butt heads as it were and
like i said i like too that much like i
kind of feel like much like home alone
you know
which is chris columbus as well uh you
know he directed it and this is the same
he wrote the screenplay for this i kind
of feel like it has the same the bad
guys in this have the same vibe as like
the wet bandits where it's kind of like
they're menacing i mean obviously
because they killed a couple of feds you
know what i mean like they were you
didn't see it but there were gunshots
and then they you find the body they
find the body later in the freezer with
a bullet hole in his head so they're
murderers
and they're counterfeiters too i didn't
get that when i was a kid they do find
the machine later that they're printing
the money on uh so yeah but they killed
a couple fbi agents so they're not like
[ __ ] around and they actually at one
point threatened to
blend
chunks hand like they kind of like are
sticking it in the blender like they're
gonna like chop his fingers off if he
doesn't talk
and so they're menacing but they're also
like kind of bumbling and i think they
did like a good job
of making them scary but also making it
believable that the kids could like
outwit them at some point you know what
i mean because i think that's kind of
like a hard
thing to that's kind of like a hard
balance to to strike i suppose you can't
make it like too scary and that's why i
just thought it was funny that like that
guy that was doing that video with his
kids that had watched the guineas with
his kids and um they thought it was a
little bit they didn't think it was like
terrifying or anything but they did
think that parts of it were a little bit
scary you know what i mean
because they're young they're like eight
or whatever so i so i could see that
because i mean that is like pretty scary
to have like murderous criminals like
running after you and threatening to
like blend your hand and [ __ ] like that
but yeah so it takes a while for the
kids to actually get to
the underground thing and like start
with and do all the booby traps and
stuff like i said at which point it gets
very indiana jones but it's like indiana
jones for kids but you know adults can
watch it too but i mean there's so many
like great [ __ ] sequences in this my
favorite one is like the bone piano like
the big skeleton with like the bone
thing where she has to play the notes
and then like makes the [ __ ]
floor drop out you know there's that
whole water slide thing and then uh when
they get to the end and that big [ __ ]
pirate ship is there
they
uh they built that pirate ship from
scratch
and it looks
fantastic
you know what's sad is that after the
movie wrapped they were trying to
sell or give the pirate ship to somebody
it's like you know anywhere a museum a
collector or something like that and
nobody wanted it
and so they just like scrapped it
can you like all that [ __ ] work and
it's like can you have it like nowadays
people would be like holy crap i wish
that [ __ ] [ __ ] was still around they
could have slapped it in a [ __ ]
museum or something it's weird because i
was in when i was in st augustine last
summer um they have a pirate and
treasure museum there and they actually
have a little room where they have a
bunch of memorabilia from movies that
had pirates in them and they did have
some memorabilia from the goonies but
i don't think it was anything they just
had like some old original posters and
maybe like a couple of little props and
stuff but that's really sad to me and
also the the original map um from the
movie i think sean aston had it and then
like his mom threw it out or something
like thinking it was garbage so again
that's like kind of sad but uh but yeah
so anyway i just kind of feel like so
they made like a video game of this they
made board games of this it was a big
huge thing and i feel like they talked
about doing a sequel but i'm really glad
they didn't what a suck it would have
sucked and honestly everybody that i've
watched because i watched like a whole
bunch of different like uh people's
takes on this and pretty much everybody
said everybody that loved this movie was
just like i'm really glad they never did
a sequel would have sucked all the air
right out of it yeah because it would
have ruined the experience of the first
one yeah you know what i mean and i just
kind of feel like
it didn't need a sequel it was it was
very self-contained
and you know that i kind of
i don't know it's and people were
talking about making a sequel like
recently like with all because most of
the cast are still alive and they're
just like oh you know they'd be the
parents of the kids and it's just kind
of like i don't even know if i want to
see that either you know what i mean i
just don't think it's i don't think it'd
be a good idea just let it be it was of
its time it's of its place it was just
that one thing and it was just like this
awesome
adventure like this fun family movie and
i really it can't be replicated nobody
needs to remake it they don't need to do
a sequel or nothing like that it's just
it's like e.t
yeah you don't [ __ ] with it you just let
it be you know yeah interestingly it's
kind of yeah et's never had a cd yeah no
because it didn't need one no
i mean this one should have taken the
guns out of it too remember they took
the guns out of the e.t and put the damn
walkie talkie stupid i mean because the
thing about it is that this i was a kid
and saw that [ __ ] [ __ ] loved it
nobody cared they didn't even notice
that there were any guns so what yeah i
mean the thing about it though is like
even if you did a sequel to the goonies
like what would it even be like because
i think the goonies
even though you could do other
quote-unquote adventures yeah i kind of
feel like the best thing one of the best
things about the goonies is the whole
pirate [ __ ] i love pirate [ __ ] yeah and
it's like you can't do pirate [ __ ] again
because the ship is gone you know what i
mean
my take on the movie is that the movie
was a masterpiece it was designed to
make money and it did that
yeah big time and it did it it was it
made money by getting kids to see it
multiple times in the theater
and to sell a bunch of merchandise
it did this by implanting itself firmly
into the minds of these kids that saw it
and it did that by telling a good story
with and it had a good tone it was a a
mainstream america
tent pole movie it had that spielbergian
kind of [ __ ] middle class vibe to it
you know what i mean where it it's
anywhere usa
uh you if you're in america even in
another country you felt like you were
in in this
kind of an idealized american setting
and uh which was a good thing because it
was kind of like something to aspire to
even if you weren't in it and then it
was like let's say you were working
class or lower class you were kind of
included in these movies too it was just
you felt like you were in with these
people
it's just a
real good tone
um
what's the optimistic very optimistic
tone to the movie yeah it definitely
does have that and and so
you you're supposed to come out of the
movies with this kind of tone and
spielberg was real good at it all right
you come out of the theater and uh
if it feels like you've re-emerged back
into the world with kind of like some
more energy in your step like ah just
you know you had a good experience
that's that was kind of uplifting
and that was just the way that those
movies were and this is this is one of
them
and um it did what it was supposed to do
it targeted the audience that it was
supposed to target which is you know
7 to 12 13 14 maybe on the outside but i
don't really have a
a connection with the movie in terms of
nostalgia i was a little too old for it
when it came out
but had i been 10 when this came out oh
i'm sure i would have [ __ ] loved that
probably remembered every line from it
probably saw it several times in the
theater
yeah and i mean i was a little bit older
i was like 12 or 13 when this came out
and i i still really really dug it
because like i said the kids in it were
12 13 somewhere around that age
and so
you really got a sense of these were
kids that
you know
their whole world was going to come
crashing down they all were going to
have to move and they weren't going to
be able to be friends anymore and they
really liked their neighborhood even
though it was kind of like a
working-class sort of area
and so they had this one last thing it's
like what if there really is this pirate
treasure that's like found and then they
go on this big long adventure and they
find it you know what i mean like the
fact that they find this [ __ ] pirate
ship and they actually like find the
jewels and they save their house and
everything like that and you know sloth
gets to go live with chunk and his
family
like and like the bad guys get punished
and the ship goes off into the sunset
and uh you know it's just like an
awesome
like you said it's a very optimistic
story and like every kid
can watch that and be like [ __ ] yeah
yeah it's like what kid would not want
to go like on a big [ __ ] pirate
adventure the only movie in recent
history that i've seen in the theater
that kind of has that spielbergian tone
that we're talking about would have been
that bumblebee movie
remember that transformers yeah movie it
it was capturing that same
80s
optimism i think it was supposed to be
taking place in the 80s one it was yeah
yeah okay yeah stranger things has that
vibe yeah stranger things probably the
the series yeah um you know and the kid
that played mikey obviously was in
stranger things too like in a minor role
like later yeah those were good times to
grow up in it was you're coming out of
the doldrums of the 70s and it's all
this bright shiny high-tech new
decade of the 80s
she was futuristic
but i was going to say too oh i forgot
there was uh there was a couple scenes
very famously that were cut out of this
right at the end like where they find
the big pirate ship and they're fighting
their fratellis and everything like that
uh there was originally a sequence where
an octopus
kind of attacked them like in the water
and they even make reference to it like
when they get out like they're even
saying to the cops um you know data says
and then there was the octopus and
everybody's like what there wasn't an
octopus but there was originally uh you
can see it on youtube it's on like the
deleted scenes and stuff they did they
shot it but it's like the octopus uh
animatronic like didn't really look all
that good
and so they just decided to scrap it i
think there was another deleted scene
too where there was like a gorilla that
escaped from a zoo or something like
that uh so they just they cut that out
too because the movie is almost two
hours long like in its finished state so
it was supposed to be
um i think the original script was
was more than two hours a lot of the
pirate stuff
looks so much like the pirates of the
caribbean caribbean right here in
[ __ ]
disneyland and disney world it makes me
wonder if they were trying to get a
little bit of crossover action going i
don't know i don't know if disney was in
any way or any way related with this or
if they're trying to piggyback something
off i don't know i mean this is amblin
entertainment which is like i said a
steven swordberg's production company so
i don't really know but i do kind of
feel like in the late 70s and early 80s
there was kind of like a little mini
pirate yeah like resurgence because
remember there was like pirates of
penzance and then they made that movie
with christy mcnichol the pirate movie
that i saw on cable probably like 400
times and then later on like a couple
years later it was hook and so
i don't know i kind of feel like there
was like a pirate thing it was almost
kind of like you know how sometimes
there's like a dinosaur thing or like a
disaster movie thing or i kind of feel
like there was a little mini pirate
thing yeah but i don't i mean they might
have been homaging
uh you know the pirates of the caribbean
ride because it did have that kind of
look to it the pirate [ __ ] honestly when
he first when he finds when he climbs up
through the thing in the pirate ship and
finds one-eyed willy's uh you know room
like with all the treasure on the table
and all the dead like all the skeletons
like the crew members like i love that i
love that production design like in that
[ __ ] i mean the pirate ship looks so
[ __ ] good
but
i don't know it's just i will say that a
couple does i mean obviously this is 85
so they're all practical effects um i
will say that a couple of the optical
shots didn't really hold up um like the
very last shot of like a one-eyed willy
ship like going off into the sunset
doesn't look that great um and also the
one shot where he's lining up the rocks
like in the doubloon um that doesn't
look that great either like like i said
it's kind of an optical or matte shot or
whatever and it doesn't really look that
good but everything else looks
fantastic but like i said this is a fun
it's almost kind of like a live-action
cartoon a little bit don't think too
much about continuity because there's
some stuff that all of these traps that
this pirate and his crew supposedly made
like underground like obviously would
not work in real life uh you know what i
mean or wouldn't work the way they're
supposed to but
[ __ ] it it's like a video game or it's
just like a fun don't think about it too
much just you know it's just like a fun
family movie adults can watch it kids
can watch it and it's kind of scary and
kind of edgy and kind of funny and you
know it's just a good time it's just a
good time for everybody and i kind of
feel like the 80s was kind of like the
heyday of that type of family film the
the 80s decade
was the time 70s late 70s too
that was an era where steve steven
spielberg is encapsulating the the um
the american middle class experience
he's encapsulating that into a
movie-like product
watch it
and you can get the vibe of what
suburbia was like
or at least supposed to be like and
that's the point of reference of most of
his stories that even goes to uh close
encounters of the third kind
okay taking place in a new suburbia
that's happening just a regular guy he
sees this damn mountain has got a thing
on top he can't he still he even grabs
the dirt from outside the house he's
throwing it in the windows the kids go
can we help that's just [ __ ] that's my
favorite
you're like that's it
that's it
i don't know why that makes me laugh
more than anything else though spielberg
knew exactly how to sell a movie
psychologically how to pull the
psychological strings in the american
viewer
to pull them into these stories
yeah definitely yep and i mean the and i
was going to say too like the funny
thing about this one i was trying to i
was thinking of like some of uh some of
the best [ __ ] lines that are some of
chunk's greatest lines where uh he was
talking about the [ __ ]
when he when he gets kidnapped by the
[ __ ] uh
criminals and like they asked him to
like tell me everything and he starts
telling every bad thing he's ever done
like his whole entire life like starting
back in [ __ ] third grade and the
whole [ __ ] about like him like them
taking the ice cream away from him and
uh him trying to like
call the cops they actually made a
gremlins reference in this
where when he calls the cops to like
report the fratellis the cop said they
don't believe him because apparently he
had called the cops a whole bunch of
times and like you know made false
reports and he said oh is this like the
time that you called and said about all
those creatures that multiply when you
throw water on them you know what i mean
so it's like they were kind of like in
universe like referring back yeah but
yeah i mean this the spielbergian trick
was to start the audience off in very
normal time space which is suburbia very
normal yeah and from that you take them
into a [ __ ] strange
yeah you're like a big adventure
adventure that's you know it's kind of
like the hero's adventure yeah you know
which he that you know that he knows he
knew what he was doing
probably because hanging out with lucas
and them talking to to uh the dude who
wrote a god of a thousand faces and
everything campbell yeah you know it's
kind of a campbell uh influence is
probably where a lot of that comes from
also um
an understanding of psychology and
propaganda which is nothing wrong with
that all advertisement is form
propaganda you start off from a baseline
and
we're trying to sell this to america to
the to the middle income that's going to
be the
baseline so that's where the story
begins
well yeah because you're trying to like
get people that's why the goonies starts
with you know obviously it has kind of
this prologue with the criminals
escaping so you can kind of have like a
fast-paced kind of thing right but then
it goes into these kids establishing
their
life their friendship right um you know
they all come over the one house they're
gathering and everything is normal
everything is normal and exposited right
like in a really efficient fashion and
you get a sense of each character each
character is interesting they each have
their own little flaws and their own
little strengths and you really get a
good sense of that like very quickly and
the kids in the audience are going oh i
like these kids they're just like me
they're just like my friends this is me
i'm in this movie that's that's the job
they live with me this is my
neighborhood yeah and that's where the
story begins yeah because everybody i
mean my you know everybody that grew up
in our era made probably nowadays too
it's like everybody knew kids like that
yeah um and they were all all of the
characters in this are distinctive yeah
and you lived in a neighborhood kind of
like that yeah they're showing you the
dead center the middle yeah you were you
lived in a place like that or a little
bit better than that or a little bit
worse than that but you can still relate
to it yeah that's what they're doing and
that's well it's very important to get
everybody kind of like on the same page
on this yeah i mean well depending on
what you want to do if you're doing like
a movie like this it's a town hall movie
yeah that you want to be like this
massive like crowd-pleasing family movie
yeah you have to establish what you know
medium baseline is you know this is
somebody that everybody can relate to
these are likable characters these are
people that are like people that you
know
and this is the situation that you're in
it's a recognizable city situation and
then we're gonna take them on this like
improbable adventure
but you know it's gonna be like a
wonderful adventure yeah he's aiming
center mass of the target that's what
you'd call it in american military aim
center mass and that's what that's what
spillway was real good with that oh yeah
big time yeah and uh yeah even though
and like i said even though richard
donner is credited with directing this a
lot of the actors later said that steven
spielberg was kind of a co-director i
mean he produced it and he was the one
that came up with the story um well
richard
well richard donner was uh steven
spielberg's mentor yeah uh so you know
what i mean another genius yeah so i
mean with all that talent but you know
behind the camera and in front of it
because like i said all the kids in this
are are great and there's like their
interactions are just so great and
naturalistic that i mean it's really
really hard
it's really difficult to dislike this
movie i mean i can't imagine
i kind of i don't know i kind of feel
like most people
if you don't like the goonies i kind of
feel like maybe
what's the matter with you
like i said it's so fun i was too old
for it when it came out but yeah i get
that i appreciate i appreciate what they
did yeah you know it's a great mechanism
it was a great
it was a great film for doing what it
was supposed to do which is make a bunch
of money and make a bunch of people
happy that's exactly what it did yeah
it definitely made me happy at the time
and it makes me happy every single time
i watch it yeah it's just it's just a
super fun movie uh but yeah so that'll
do it for our movie retrospective on the
goonies
uh tell me what you thought about the
goonies did you see it back in the 80s
uh did you have you watched it with your
kids what did they think about it i'm
really actually curious about that uh
tell me about that in the comments and
we will see you guys on the next movie
retrospective bye
you